so 17 18 meine lieben freunde oder
kollegen gehört mir wurde extremst oft
die app dort ab empfohlen was ich genau
die schalte ist die ich immer spiele und
deswegen wird
luca spielt deswegen fangen wir auch
schon direkt an gedrückten einfach auf
play und jetzt muss ich spiele zum
ersten mal da steht tepco
und jetzt muss ich hier irgendwie
hochschulen das erinnert mich so ein
bisschen swing pop das und es wurde mir
und zwar wurde das spiel von einer
freundin empfohlen die hat dann nämlich
einen highscore geschafft der höher ist
der ist erwähnt von stumpfer vergeben
zwar hat sie den highscore 10 geschafft
und meinte ich schaff das nimmer hier
hat man nämlich auch im bild geschickt
von ihrem heiß kochen zwar ist es dass
hier die meinte hey ich habs 25
geschafft aber mein highschools 10 bei
dem schauspiel spiel das doch auch mal
runtergeladen und ich habe jetzt aber
auch schon neun geschafft und ich bin
damit eigentlich schon recht zufrieden
also ich weiß nicht ich finde ich
schlage mich gerade recht so ein spiel
habe ich so lange gesucht liebe diese
kleinen spiele die einfach extrem simpel
sind alter es muss echt alles
aufeinander abgestimmt sein wenn man
einmal so stoppen muss am anfang geht
das noch aber am ende wenn diese teil so
richtig riesig werden coupé jetzt jetzt
kann ich doch immer so abwarten bis die
mir ein bisschen platz machen aber jetzt
gleich wird das so richtig ekelhaft sie
jetzt schon und jetzt jetzt jetzt gibt's
auch noch eigentlich das spielrecht sie
alle malen soll dort ab da regst du dich
voll auf dich voll ich scheiß laden
kommt gehe ich hier durch hierdurch safe
locker schon magische 12 13 14
und jetzt macht die 15 da macht die 16
17 18 ding für mich 19 jetzt gehe ich
hier eben durch 20
21 22 23 24 25 26 nike john ist es
wieder so eine scheiße um ihr alter ich
hab einfach 26 geschafft man jetzt
gesehen wohin ich hab diese scheiße hier
darauf wirklich noch nie gespielt ich
habe am anfang mit euch das tutorial
gemacht das ist einfach wirklich sowie
swing pop das nur einfach dachte ich reg
mich immer richtig viel auf und so und
hab schon extra wieder nachbarin
gewerblich nehmen auf bitte nicht
beschweren
und jetzt ist das hier einfach so eine
idee die siege sache alter das ist ja
mal richtig einfach dieses spiel sich
weiß nicht mehr gefällt aber ich bin gut
in chains laden vor allem die passende
sich mehr an
ich kann einfach so durchgehen ich muss
teilweise nicht mehr warten und so kommt
jetzt ich bin positiv überrascht von
diesem spiel
ich weiß nicht was ich dazu sagen soll
weil das ganze ich ein
ich dachte wirklich ich weiß doch gar
nicht was ich hat kommentieren soll
normalerweise rast sich bei solchen
scheiß einmal richtig aus aber ich bin
richtig begeistert von mir mein mann
mein ziel ist auf jeden fall dass auch
scheiß hug und paco alter darum ist
einfach so richtig geile werbung von
spicy chicken bürger dadurch gerade
richtig bock drauf aber ich habe jetzt
zeit für mit seinen ernährungsplan
zusammengestellt das nicht so ein
bisschen gesünder leben weil ich mir
sonst immer so
irgendwann in der nacht pizza bestellen
weil ich dann noch lernen oder irgendwie
sowas mache alter das wird jetzt das war
richtig knapp man aber jetzt sondern
sonst wär schon falsch muss ich
natürlich sagen aber ich dachte echt
wirklich freunde
es tut mir sehr leid falls irgendwie
gedacht re der spielten elf dann reicht
er wieder weil es möglich aber nicht
wenn ich das nicht mag mögt ihr dass es
irgendwie total paradox wenn ich ein
spiel hasse das direkt an das gute video
falle geraten
jeffrey match cookies to create hassia
solche spiele das sind alles so candy
crash sachen alles kein ding für king
ich werde erst mal wieder direkt ein
highscore machen die teile passen sich
wieder
ich gehen die sich in die richtung
drehen ist alles frisch aber wenn sie
sich in die andere richtung drehen dann
isch scheiß teile ich würde man gern
noch mal höher als als 26 jetzt kommen
das war echt klasse ich habe einfach
beim zweiten rang direkt eine freundin
von mir überboten die das spiel einfach
schon so seit 20 trilliarden trillionen
jsp riskanten kurs spielt
okay das war echt scheiße gibt ja echt
leute die einfach nur previews auf ihren
kanälen hochladen also nur so applets
place ich frag mich echt was kommentiert
man denn da alter ich bin ich das
einzige was ich mal kommentieren wenn
ich irgendwelche apps socke ist dass
sich rum schreie quasi weil mich die app
aufregt aber wenn ich jetzt so was hätte
wo ich nicht rum schreien würde dann
wisst ihr kugel immer diese hufen kacke
dass ich oben rechts und ein paar
sekunden warten muss bis sich das
überhaupt mal wegklicken kann das ist so
eine schachtel mconie macht doch einfach
mal den flugmodus rein
die kommt ja nicht jede werbung habe ich
nutze eine app zum aufnehmen die
internet benötigt da bin ich über wlan
mit meinem pc verbunden deswegen habe
ich auch kein kabel und kann das ganze
hier einfach wie ich will irgendwo rum
schleudern deswegen ist es doch echt
scheiße wenn ich da den flugmodus
ausmachen würde
aber ich würde sagen ich mache jetzt
eben noch schnell neuen highscore also
mir ist das wirklich ein rätsel wie
kammern bitte bei app review soderbergh
displays da viel zu reden das ist
unmöglich bei solchen sachen ich wüsste
nicht was ich sagen soll außer wird
schreien aber ich muss nicht fallen weil
ich das spiel mag eigentlich gipfel
kommen elf kommt
13 jetzt ihr da oben stellt mal ein
bisschen 14
das ist easy hier 15 ich hasse nur diese
teile die man auf uns zugehen so 17 18
jungen dieses cookie dem alltag jedoch
einfach weg du blöder shake the target
ist territories impossible von mikus
ich glaube man es gut in dem spiel wenn
man es wirklich so zum ersten mal
spielen einfach so auf gut glück geht
aber so mit der zeit wenn man sich zu
immer mehr gedanken darum macht dann
geht's halt scheiße das ist genauso wie
mit mit mit youtube wenn man seinen
kanal zu sehr professionalisiert dann
ist er auch wieder schlecht weil die
leute so sehe ich das halt immer die
leute wollen einfach youtuber die real
sind deswegen weiß nicht womit ich diese
ganze paket in verbindung setzte das ist
nämlich einfach nur so einen scheiß
spiel wahrscheinlich übersteuert auch
grad meinem eine tonspur
das sind immer so millimeter
entscheidungen hier ich möchte nur noch
einmal mein highscore knacken damit ich
dir jetzt nicht nach diesem video nur 26
cent muss übrigens die weiß gar nicht
dass ich gute wichtiges machen damit ich
nach diesem video hier nicht nur 26 er
zeigen kann sondern einfach mal
irgendwie sowas 26
und ich bin richtig guten weg komm komm
hier ich schaff das alter das war
richtig fies ok 21 22 das ist auf jeden
fall mein letzter dran weil ich werde
das jetzt schaffen ich glaub an mich
bruder 25 26 27
das ist schon mal richtig geil 28 29
das war richtig damit will ich aber
sagen meine lieben freunde ich bin mir
der tonspur schon bei minute elf ich
denke aber nachher wird irgendwie so auf
67 minuten runter gekürzt oder so
welches nicht schneiden
wenn ihr mehr von apps volt und wenn ihr
die app kennt wo ihr sagt der pizza dem
film ein schnäppchen in die kommentare
und dann würde ich mich freuen wenn ihr
das video mit ihm habe ich schon gesagt
den daumen hoch geben